it is March 23 2023 and you are watching
the code report well another day another
step towards the singularity GitHub just
announced copilot X their next-gen
coding assistant powered by Bard or no
excuse me gpt4 and it makes the old
co-pilot look like a child's toy these
AI tools are like anabolic steroids the
developers using them get a huge
advantage and within the next two years
nobody coding professionally is going to
be Natty if you're someone who loves to
code like me or a student learning how
to code you might feel a bit pessimistic
right now all of our open source code
stack Overflow answers and tutorials
have been used to build large language
models that are now being aggressively
deployed to automate white-collar jobs I
drink your milkshake
but programming is not dead personally I
feel extremely grateful to be living
through these times 150 years from now
when our heads are stored in a jar of
preservative jelly we'll be telling our
great-great-great-grandkids how we lived
through the great AI inflection point of
2023 resistance is futile if you want to
survive you have to be optimistic these
tools will only make us more powerful AI
still can't deliver a great product to
the end user and will need programmers
who understand how to build these
systems but now they'll be able to build
them 10 times faster thanks to AI
tooling it's a great time to be alive if
you love building things the scary thing
though is that Microsoft is
single-handedly dominating the space
they've been on a blitzkrieg attack this
last week releasing product after
product Bing chat co-pilot for office
Bing image generator and now co-pilot
acts you have to give Microsoft credit
for not killing off Bing years ago
despite over a decade of people trashing
it they also acquired GitHub and took a
major stake in open Ai and now in just a
week's time all of their products look
years ahead of the competition Saudia
just gave us a free master class and
business strategy case in point GitHub
copilot X it's currently in technical
preview so you can can't use it today
but it has at least five game changing
features the big one is its built-in
chat window with this tool you'll be
able to highlight a block of code and
ask it for an explanation or ask it to
refactor it or better yet have it
generate some unit tests these are
things you can already do today with
chat GPT but now it'll be highly
specialized for coding problems directly
in your IDE but most importantly it'll
have the context of your actual code
base remember gpt4 can handle 25 000
tokens versus only 3 000 tokens in GPT
3.5 feature number two is copilot for
documentation instead of going to the
actual docs or stack Overflow you'll now
be able to generate answers based on a
specific library's documentation they're
integrating the docs for react Azure and
mdn allowing you to generate answers and
tutorials on the fly a feature that
terrifies me because it will make me
obsolete as a programming instructor but
feature 3 is the one I'm most excited
about voice activated copilot the need
to be an extremely fast typist who can
churn out 150 words per minute in Vim
will be far less important in the AI
programming age
after use your hands that's like a
baby's toy it's now possible to control
vs code and write code entirely from
voice commands this is a feature I've
always dreamed about because not only is
it faster than typing but it allows you
to write code when you otherwise
couldn't like when you're running on the
treadmill or on your commute to work the
keyboard won't become obsolete but it'll
revolutionize the way things get done in
the same way Alexa changed the way
people do things in the household
feature number four is copilot for pull
requests whenever I submit a pull
request to an important project I have a
nervous breakdown trying to figure out
the description because why would anyone
want to merge my garbage code well now
copilot can generate that description
for you based on the changes that you
made to the code which were probably
made by AI anyway and finally we have
feature number five the copilot CLI AI
autocompletion will not just happen in
the text editor but also in the terminal
there's no longer a need to memorize
endless Linux commands you just tell it
what you want to do with a certain
Library like ffmpeg and it will generate
the command along with an explanation
from there you can run it or revise it
if needed looks pretty awesome so when
do I get to use it well that I don't
know I would say it's at least months
away from being ready for public
consumption and that gives us a small
window to write the worst code we
possibly can and put it on GitHub do
poison the training data so all of us
HTML programmers can keep our six-figure
jobs and lastly I would like to salute
all the real programmers of the last 30
years who wrote the billions of lines of
code that make this Beast possible the
cruel irony is that many of them were
Linux users who hated Microsoft but
little did they know they were working
for Microsoft for free the whole time
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one